[Musique]
non
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire le ministre de l'éducation
nationale jean michel blanquer revient
de lancer son think tank le laboratoire
républicain qui veut défendre
l'humanisme et l'universalisme face au
wac isme mais qu'est ce que c'est que
cette idéologie walk à laquelle la
jeunesse française doit absolument
échapper d'après jean michel blanquer
est ce que c'est le nouvelliste a beau
gauchisme est ce que c'est le nouveau
politiquement correct en 2018 le monde
expliquait que le web c'était le nouveau
cool trois ans plus tard c'est devenu un
fléau en provenance des états unis qui
est d'après la secrétaire d'état à la
jeunesse sarah lahiri l'opposé de
l'histoire de france alors qu'en est il
exactement qu'est ce qui se cache
derrière ce terme pour débattre nous
avons invité pierre valentin vous êtes
membre du laboratoire républicain que
vient de créer le ministre de
l'éducation nationale vous êtes l'auteur
de deux notes publiées par le think tank
fondapol intitulé l'idéologie walk
anatomy duo kyste et l'idéologie web
face au voc isme sinon vous êtes
étudiant en master de sciences
politiques à l'université paris ii est
diplômé de philosophie et de politiques
de l'université d'exeter alors pour vous
c'est quoi le hoki sme le gothisme c'est
une gauche sur deux dire que on a
entendu parler à quelques années des
deux gauches irréconciliables et on a
une gauche qui croit en l'art au
rationalisme à l'universalisme à
l'existence même de l'individu et une
autre gauche qui voit tous ces
différents concepts là comme autant de
fiction blanche comme de construction
sociale fait part des dominants et
j'aimerais poser juste de en fait de
sophismes et qui sont souvent opposés à
ceux qui disent ça pour le reste du
débat le premier c'est une forme de
sophismes un syllogisme par
l'association hitler aime bien de
parents tranche vous monsieur aimait
bien le pas en tranches la conclusion
s'impose d'elle-même parfois les mots
qui sont encore plus fort ce qu'ils vont
dire une fois vos avis si tu es
quelqu'un qui a cité quelqu'un qui a
cité quelqu'un qui une fois bien aimé le
parent tranche donc vous êtes pareils
que hitler vous aussi est un autre
sophisme et qui arrive souvent c'est une
variante du soleil qui le domine m si
vous parlez de ça c'est que vous avez un
problème en fait avec les minorités si
vous parlez de ça c'est que vous empêche
de parler des vrais sujets qui fait
diversion sire que moi je me serais levé
tous les matins pendant des mois pour
travailler sur ce sur ses notes en me
disant que j'ai un vrai problème avec
les femmes c'est ce qui motive le matin
en me levant et j'espère que ce soit on
ne verront pas c'est sophie ce mois là
parce que pour l'instant des débats et
que j'ai eu sur ces sujets là c'est
généralement ce qui se passe elle bat un
wagner vous vous êtes docteur en
sciences du langage chercheur associé à
l'université rennes 2 et à l'inalco
spécialisé dans les transformations
politiques et l'analyse de discours
votre dernier livre c est qu archi
manifeste pour la fin des démocraties
nous capitaliste néolibéral c'est paru
aux éditions du croquant vous êtes
également l'auteur du débat sur
l'identité nationale et c'est à propos
d'un fantôme c'était chez l'harmattan et
de discours et systèmes chez peter lang
alors pour vous c'est quoi ce walk isme
mais pour moi ce qui se meut c'est
surtout un anathème qui est utilisé par
une certaine forme de droite
conservatrice pour en fait cibler des
demandes qui sont des demandes qui sont
plutôt liées à la justice sociale et à
une forme de reconnaissance de la
diversité et tout ça va en fait avec une
modification profonde de la société
alors ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'effectivement il y à là quelque chose
de fondamental par rapport à on va dire
au modèle républicain universaliste et à
une certaine forme d'idéologie que moi
j'appelle à l'idéologie républicaine
east pour être très très clair qui va en
fait un carnet effectivement une espèce
de comment dire
qui va incarner finalement les valeurs
de la république liberté égalité
fraternité et son quatrième mousquetaire
la laïcité
s'avère en fait des discours église
cours qui vont souvent vouloir se
référer à eux mêmes avant tout c'est à
dire que on préfère se dire que comme ce
discours là existent comme finalement on
a ces mots clés la liberté égalité
fraternité laïcité ça veut dire que sur
le terrain c'est forcément appliqué et
ça existe forcément or il ya tout un
ensemble d'individus qui ne vivent pas
l'égalité au quotidien qui ne vivent pas
la liberté de la fraternité certainement
pas au quotidien et qui ont envie de
faire bouger les lignes par rapport à ça
et de justement pouvoir être reconnu
dans la dignité et en général le
problème c'est que lorsque ces
demandes-là émergent on a en face
systématiquement à mur c'est le mur du
gauchisme qui renvoie l'autre en fait à
ses demandes un peu comme une comme une
injure finalement alors revenons sur sur
l'origine de ce mot wow que pour moi
c'est martin luther king dans un
discours en 1965 qui dit au jeune
américain starwood rester éveillé et
veiller au sens vigilant vigilants aux
discriminations aux injustices c'est un
terme qui a repris par icade erykah badu
dans une chanson en 2008 high stakes
brook je reste vigilante s'est repris
ensuite par black lips matters toujours
sur le même thème restons vigilants aux
discriminations aux injustices si tel
article du monde en 2018 qui qui dit
bleu lui manque c'est le nouveau call
passion et bi tout à coup ça devient
l'horreur absolue là j'ai cité le
ministre de l'éducation nationale et la
secrétaire d'état à la jeunesse mais
j'aurais pu citer à peu près tous les
hommes politiques et les femmes
politiques se sont
définis récemment par rapport aux quais
à part sandrine rousseau qui a fait une
campagne en se réclamant du gaullisme
c'est la plupart des autres sont
toujours en ti book alors de grâce à une
évolution très récente pour le coup ça
vraiment quelques mois
pour revenir un peu vous avez parlé de
martin luther king il y a une à mon sens
une stratégie walk est assez efficace
qui est de vouloir se placer dans son
sillon sauf que il ya par exemple la
théorie critique de la race qui est
vraiment très populaire en amérique
parmi les branches différentes du
gaullisme qui avec notamment nos british
art delgado agent stéphane chic qui sont
les ceux qui ont écrit un manuel sur la
théorie critique de l'aragon qui s'en
réclament ouvertement ils expliquent eux
mêmes voire sur blanc contrairement au
mouvement des droits civiques
traditionnel la théorie critique de la
race remet en cause les fondements mêmes
de l'ordre libéral le rationalisme des
lumières l'égalité devant le droit etc
etc dont il assume dans certains
certains cas pas toujours publiquement
d'être complètement contre cet héritage
là et si une certaine logique parce que
comme l'a bien démontré notamment
l'intellectuel français pierre andré
taguieff il y à un paradoxe constitutif
au sens de ce nouvel anti racisme qui
trahit l'ancien c'est que on se
gargarise de racialiser au nom de
l'antiracisme c'est à dire que là où
martin luther king disait je veux
d'abord qu'on juge en fait sur le
contenu du caractère des uns et les
autres ils n'ont pas sur la couleur de
peau là on se gargarise de percevoir la
race et de percevoir la société à
travers les grilles raciale ce qui est
précisément là envers tout ce qu'ils
voulaient faire donc moi s'est il
m'apporte beaucoup de faire ce distinguo
là dès le début du débat vous êtes
d'accord albin wagner
si vous voulez moi je pense que en fait
on mélange beaucoup de choses en fait
dans ces accusations par rapport au kiss
me par rapport au mouvement au qui
effectivement
d'abord à son creuset culturel et
politique historique en fait dans bord
dont les états unis
la difficulté c'est que
souvent en fait comme vous voyez des
ministres des hommes des chats politique
dérouler leur argumentaire sur le voc
isme sur le maître télé ils vont
toujours dire le mot qui soit en danger
pour la république la preuve aux états
unis il ya ça et ça et ça nous prend la
cité des exemples purement américain en
disant que ces exemples montrent qu' il
ya un an j'ai en france or en france il
ya quand même excessivement vodka ou en
fait on se retrouve devant effectivement
des situations un petit peu absurde
comme il peut y en avoir aux états unis
mais cette façon de bureaucratiser ou
judiciariser finalement les rapports
sociaux ne date pas finalement de la
question du gaullisme aux etats unis
c'est quelque chose qui est aussi le
constitutifs d'un autre fonctionnement à
la fois politique sociale etc je pense
qu'il faut aussi raison garder là d'ssus
pire autre chose aussi tu voudrais quand
même dire c'est que le voc isme est le
digne successeur de l'islamo gauchisme
sur lequel je me suis aussi penché et
les critiques finalement de l'islamo
gauchisme puis du moc isme sont aussi ça
ont eux aussi l'idéologie il faut quand
même pas oublier que pierre andré
taguieff par exemple où toute la joyeuse
mans de l'observatoire du colonialisme a
quand même aussi un positionnement qui
est idéologique de fait donc la
problématique aussi et l'ajout de pose
en tant que chercheur s'il pouvait me
permettre ça de quoi parle-t-on
finalement et qu'est-ce qu'on étudie
commence on regarde les choses à se dire
les choses avec un prisme qui va
fatalement abandonné les hommes et des
femmes politiques par lettre à prismes
nécessairement idéologique mais je le
dis voilà enfin c'est comme ça quelle
que soit l'idéologie de gauche ou de
droite c'est ça
mais de l'autre côté en fait on va créer
une inflation dans le discours de termes
comme il s'émeut gauchisme comme avant
on parle effectivement de politiquement
correct on a parlé aussi de deux sgw
avant les siennes au gauchisme et les
search of this way justement qui m'a
lancé voky sme
on va en fait ils ensemble dans les mois
qui viennent parler de théorie critique
de la race et dans six mois et d'un
indice sera encore autre chose donc on a
comme ça tout un ensemble de ribambelle
de paniques morales qui sont créés par
une certaine droite française est restée
réactionnaire il faut aussi le dire
aussi et vous avez cette droite là qui
s'inspire aussi de pratiquer
intellectuels conservateurs américains
ou d'autres personnalités comme rush
lino qui terrorise clairement le fait
que là je fais référence vraiment à la
polémique sur l'islam aux gauchistes
mais qui théorisent le fait que pour
pouvoir m comment dire mettre le projet
conservateur au centre de la vie
politique il faut d'abord s'attaquer aux
universités cette théorie yahsat et
écrire aux états unis ça quand même donc
en fait je dis pas qu'il n'y a pas
d'abus dans les universités américaines
il y en a effectivement à la fois du
côté du camp de ceux qui défendent des
diversités et aussi du côté conservateur
parce qu'il ya aussi des habits de ce
côté là on en parle malheureusement pas
assez mais bon c'est comme ça mais ce
que je veux dire c'est que le
le terrain le terroir américain
étasunien n'est pas le même que le
pouvoir français et la manière dont le
goût qui se meut s'invite finalement
dans cette pré campagne présidentielle
parce que c'est aussi ça le contexte il
faut aussi remettre dans la peau texte
toute politique nationale la façon dont
seront qui s'invite c'est aussi une
forme d'auto défense d'une certaine d'un
certain modèle républicain de cette
idéologie république à nice tu dans un
article récent en dies je m'amuse et
même à appeler ça des républiques du
jambon beurre mais où en fait finalement
on a l'impression que le simple fait de
parler des valeurs républicaines sade et
incarne c'est ce qu'on appelle la parole
performative on est vraiment là dedans
dans la théorie des actes de langage et
donc on va créer alors ça c'est bon
c'est mon point de vue et c'est vraiment
basé sur ce que j'ai pu faire enfin
comme recherche on va donc être est ce
qu'on appelle mon en théorie de
l'argumentation l'argument de l'homme de
paille dont je crée un homme de paille
et je me bats contre cet homme de paille
c'est à dire que dès que quelqu'un à
gauche dit qu'il faudrait faire
attention aux droits de certaines
minorités qu'elles soient par exemple
handicapées qu'elles soient
effectivement 1,6 et comment veulent
vraiment venir dans certains quartiers
que 7e arr etc on va dire tout de suite
que c'est du mot qui s'est donc on va se
battre contre cet épouvantail cette
stratégie de l'homme de paille elle
fonctionne toujours très bien et
finalement ça reflète assez bien
d'ailleurs le
j'ai dit que la manière dont le fonds
conservateur a plus évolué depuis la fin
des années 80 et c'est étudié assez
longuement dans les analyses critiques
de discours d'ailleurs depuis 1989 à peu
près est ce que la question c'est est-ce
que sandrine rousseau est une femme de
paille dans la mesure où elle incarne le
terme est ce que elle même se caricature
on a par exemple au royaume uni il ya à
ce stade encore aujourd'hui 18% des
personnes qui se réclament du terme dans
un sondage de yougov réalisé cette année
donc allez dire à ces gens là vous ce
que vous défendez n'a aucun sens n'a
aucune cohérence ne veut rien dire ça a
été inventé par des gens qui vous aiment
pas alors que évidemment comme on l'a
dit c'est un terme qui est d'abord
positif c'est une revendication jack
dorsey le président de twitter en 2016
encore arboré un tee shirts des work
ensuite vous dites que c'est uniquement
américain moi je suis assez fasciné par
ça on a eu récemment calliopée grenoble
des personnes des professeurs qui ont eu
leurs noms placardisé quelques mois
après la décapitation de ces mâles pâtit
donc un contexte où poumon avait ça en
tête en fait le nom de deux professeurs
accusé d'islamophobie lorsqu'on fait ça
dans ce contexte là l'intention est
claire il ya des dominants qui aurait
commis un péché de blasphème qu'il
faudrait abattre ou en tout cas disons
que le risque est assumé et la police
elle même a jugé que ce risque était
assez fort pour les placer sous
protection policière quand on dit que ça
n'existe pas en france je suis fascinée
allez dire vous même à ces deux
professeurs en fait ce qui a eu avec
vous ça n'a pas eu lieu le gothisme
n'existe pas ce qui vous est arrivé n'a
pas eu lieu rassurez vous ça n'a pas eu
lieu allez dire ça ces gens là moi je
serais très frappé de très curieux de
voir leur réaction là dessus et il y à
il ya aussi on veut parler de stratégie
un peu de disqualifiante c'est cette
même gauche je parle pas pour vous
monsieur je parle pour en général cette
même gauche look qui extrême droitiste
tout désaccord c'est à dire que caroline
forest aujourd'hui il faut le savoir et
d'extrême droite raphaël enthoven
aujourd'hui idées d'extrême droite il
abaisse badinter universaliste de gauche
et d'extrême droite et donc on a
surnommé la qui se passe et c'est déjà
les personnes citées évidemment ne se
réclame pas d'extrême droite ensuite
personne aujourd'hui publiquement dans
le débat public ne se réclame d'extrême
droite et eux ça les dérange pas pour le
coup de faire un vrai homme de paille et
d'hommes de palliser tous leurs
opposants d'extrême droite is et de
pathologies telles des accords avec des
influx des insultes suffixe en fob un
phoque on ne débat pas avec un fold on
lanternes il souffre d'une phobie en art
nos forums je n'ai pas lu sortir des des
sources des faits des arguments logiques
pour le dire que les araignées ne sont
pas dangereuses je le soignais c'est
comme ça qu'on traite le désaccord dans
le lotissement je trouve que c'est une
certaine ironie que d'accuser ceux qui
critiquent leur autisme de faire ça à
eux mêmes ben wagner moi je pense qu'il
sauva non plus quelque part de succomber
à cette espèce de comment dire ce que
moi je voudrais le gros titre risque
c'est à dire que il ya forcément une
anecdote toujours pour étayer affaire
toujours est ce que c'est une anecdote
qui statistiquement valable est assez
régulier ou est ce que c'est une
anecdote évidemment que les enseignants
de l'iep grenoble qui ont vécu ça c'est
pas agréable du tout on est bien
d'accord il s'agit pas de dire que ce
qu'ils ont vécu une existence
c'est une réalité en revanche le
contexte aussi a été largement
retravaillé pour expliquer et comprendre
pourquoi on en est arrivé là aussi un
donc dans tout fait social est aussi une
généalogie donc il faut aussi regarder
pourquoi faisant dériver les cheveux en
train de dire que ce qui leur arrive et
est arrivé justement c'est profondément
injuste mais il ya un contexte à diego
dames c'est ceci dit un cas non c'est
intéressant de vous parler de saigner le
pâtis puisque justement
d'à côté on a effectivement cette
progression là de l'autre analystes de
l'éducation nationale qui justement
quelques jours je vais pas ce que dira
quelques heures après la commémoration
des de l'année enfin si j'ose dire après
ce talent et de l'assassinât de sami yen
pâtit en fait je mets en garde les profs
de défendre les valeurs de république
c'est ce que j'appelle moi le
républicanisme ont effectivement là
dedans on apprend le christ des
positions et c'est ça en fait à la
pourront en tout cas la problématique du
débat c'est en fin de vie soit des
positions est on en train de regrouper
des gens dans un camp comme dans l'autre
d'ailleurs puisque les six des personnes
que vous citez un phénomène qui aura une
forest par exemple travaillent
régulièrement ensemble dans tel ou tel
projet ne soit de rédaction soit thing
temps et c'est donc le bon sens même des
gens qui justement nous lissons des
intellectuels mais il représente surtout
un groupe d'intellectuels l'accord avec
une façon de voir les choses d'une façon
il faudra évidemment une pensée rich
wilson voix d'extrême-droite sais pas ce
que je fais c'est à dire qu'il
comprenait qu'il évoque les thèmes
d'extrême droite c'est ce que j'essaie
de vous dire c'est eux qui extrême
droitiser qui empêche le désaccord ça
s'est levé le sophisme de
disqualification de l'adversaire sans
traiter les arguments de fond on voit
pas dire qu'il ya un problème avec le
lotissement va dire ceux qui parlent du
vox pour son extrême droite sens du
débat
on veut aussi dire que les conservateurs
très tôt fait tout ce qu'ils ont fait
d'accord avec lui deux bloquistes fin du
débat
mais avec notamment positivement et
l'extrême droite avocats non non non
c'est pas mal entendu parce que je pense
que l'on est une figure par exemple
mocky sme et mouvements boxer sont des
choses vraiment différente pour moi
autant effectivement l'otan
effectivement le mouvement hawk que vous
avez d'ailleurs parfaitement bien décrit
à une histoire qui est vraiment lié en
fait à l'émancipation des noirs aux
états unis puis en fait en général au
mouvement des droits civiques autant le
bouddhisme la manière dont vous qui sont
actuellement je lis bien est utilisée
est d'abord principalement utilisés par
les adversaires du gauchisme d'accord
est ce que j'appelle moi en fait un
extrait vidéo le jem c'est à dire en
fait un élément en fait idéologique
linguistique utilisé d'abord par un camp
la droite comme il existe d'ailleurs des
sinistres ont mis des allogènes des
éléments linguistiques désolé pour le
déterrement mais bon c'est pour séparer
les choses qui sont utilisées
principalement par la gauche justement
pour qualifier ou disqualifier ce sont
des choses qui existent dans les deux
camps moi donc moi ce que je vois c'est
que c'est pour ça que je parle
d'anathème dans le dans le cas d'une vo
quy sme et je pars de boue qui s'est pas
de mouvement où ce sont deux choses pour
moi qui sont très très différentes et la
musique on le voit la façon dont cette
terre dans l'oeuf est prospère ce sont
vraiment des trajectoires différentes
on ne peut pas on ne peut pas les mettre
côte à côte ce faire les mélanges et si
je veux dire vraiment apprécié
maintenant le 400 vidéos vous avez cités
très intéressant il est intéressant
parce que d'abord elle est le père l'a
finalement de second tour mais a un peu
de choses très peu de pourcentage
en fait et puis surtout elle a remis
dans des spas publics quelque part une
façon de faire du débat qui jusque là
effectivement été totalement inexistant
en france et je voulais vraiment revenir
là dessus parce que pour moi c'est
quelque chose d'important c'est pas le
fait que sandrine roux sur le fasse ou
pas ça la limite c'est un prétexte si
j'ose dire mais le fait qu'on inflige
des débats de notre manière quand je
parle le républicanisme quand je parle
de cette parole performative et j'y
tiens c'est qu'on a souvent les mêmes
intellectuels les mêmes jamais les mêmes
femmes politiques qui depuis en fait des
années de plateau en plateau d'élection
en élection
explique en fait la france est un pays
universaliste et que donc tout et tous
sont libres et égaux en droits non ça
c'est quelque chose qui est tout à fait
amis dans la gêne à logique politique et
philosophique de l'état républicain bon
ceci étant dit on peut aussi avoir une
démocratie tout à fait saine sans
république enfin je veux dire dans la
mesure où c'est un modèle que la france
a choisi par la france a choisi
l'histoire de la france s'est imposée
comme ça
mais le problème c'est que vous avez des
citoyennes et des citoyens et on va pas
non plus dire que leur parole n'a aucun
sens qui vivent en fait ce qui ne vivent
pas ses valeurs au quotidien qui disent
très bien on me dit à longueur de
plateaux télé ou de radio que ces
valeurs sont les valeurs de république
et que donc elle existe et que donc elle
s'incarne mais dans mon quartier mais
dans la façon de percevoir en fait le
monde mais dans mon expérience je ne dis
pas ça du tout il y existe des
inégalités il existe en fait des
libertés qui ne sont pas totalement
abouti en fonction de la manière dont
vous place dans la société et
effectivement sans vouloir effectivement
aller sur le paradigme de l'homme blanc
hétérosexuel même s'il ya des choses
beaucoup à en dire aussi effectivement
le fait qu' il existe encore une
différence nous parce que ça de salaire
entre les hommes et des femmes c'est
quand même ce sont des statistiques qui
devrait alerter le fait que les femmes
ont des métiers plus précaire que les
hommes en général sauf si ça devrait
alerter donc tout ça ce sont quand même
les inégalités et je préfère gras et moi
qu'on se
positionne et qu'on essaie de travailler
pourquoi pas grâce aux valeurs
républicaines d'ailleurs g7 sur ces
inégalités là plutôt qu effectivement de
jeter en fait l'opprobre sur ceux qui
disent bien on vit ces inégalités
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait je comprends
alors il ya deux choses là on a parlé
donc la question de la catégorie femmes
et on a parlé du fait que
selon ce qu'on a entendu
il y aurait des gens qui en fait accepte
du projet républicain mais trouve qu'il
a été mal appliquée et mal abouti
philosophiquement c'est vraiment pas le
cas on a des personnes par exemple
aurélia bouteldja qui n'est pas qu'ils
ne pensent pas que l'universalisme
français est bien là était mal appliquée
ne sont pas d'accord avec l'existence
même de l'universalisme elle va dire par
exemple le jeu cartésien va jeter les
fondements philosophiques de la blanche
cité donc elle ne croit pas en sa en
fait c'est pas des gens qui disent vous
avez un système qui est vraiment sympa
mais il faudrait nuancer et l'appliquer
un peu mieux et aller au bout de votre
promesse c'est d'ailleurs justement si
l' on veut revenir un peu sur le sujet à
l'américain dans les années 60 qu'est ce
qui a fait le succès des droits civiques
de martin luther king c'est notamment de
dire l'amérique trahit sa propre
promesse de liberté de l'égalité des uns
et des autres je vais faire en sorte que
l'amérique accompli sa promesse ce qui
arrive après c'est pas le cas c'est de
dire par exemple on a dans un ouvrage
qui s'appelle 14 192 l'occultation de
l'autre cette idée que l'amérique est né
en 480 12 ans génocide en les
amérindiens et donc dans son essence
même ce rêve ici serait mauvaise serait
à jeter il ya aussi le sixtine nineteen
project en amérique également que je
fais par des historiens notamment du new
york times qui cherche cherche à
expliquer ce qui est fondamental à
l'amérique celle esclavage et lorsqu'on
a fait ça lorsqu'on a expliqué que le
problème était fondamental et non pas
une mauvaise application de bons
principes on légitime la décolonisation
qui me disent la déconstruction de
toutes ces choses là il ne cherche pas à
amender un modèle ils cherchent à
détruire un modèle j'aimerais très clair
là dessus ensuite vous avez parlé la
catégorie femmes excusez moi mais cette
catégorie réactionnaire monsieur elle
n'existe plus dans l'autisme la femme a
un manque de fluidité la femme qu'il ya
une réalité biologique derrière il
faudrait la fluidifier la déconstruire
aujourd'hui la nouvelle catégorie qui
rentre en contradiction cela on peut
parler d'un terreau sexualité qui furent
à mesure que ces luttes se multiplient
elles se divisent finalement et bien la
femme rentre en contradiction avec le
trans donc pour ne pas entendre ses fans
le transgenre sessad oncle l'homme qui
devient femme et donc pourquoi les
offenses et on dit plus femme j'espère
que vous serez pas traiter près
actionnaires pour avoir prononcé ce
terme là ce soir monsieur on dit
personne qui monstrueux ou alors comme
l'a fait la revue scientifique the land
sept corps avec un vagin donc maintenant
allez me dire que ça va défendre les
femmes on voit d'ailleurs aussi
récemment c'est à dire un vrai sujet de
plus en plus des doutes des hommes par
exemple qui physiquement forcément on
une musculature en moyenne bien
supérieur aux femmes qui vont au dernier
moment en rentrant dans une compétition
d'haltérophilie on a vu ça aux
olympiques récemment se déclarer femme
est évidemment que la concurrence est
faussée et la femme qui aura fait si
vous voulez de cette compétition
d'altérer der haltérophilie ou de rugby
aux autres son grand rêve au dernier
moment se faire abattre par quelqu'un
d'autre est là on dira non mais le
gothisme défend les femmes le nautisme a
largué la famille en a rien à faire
l'autisme n'avait rien à faire des
minorités en général parce que comme on
l'a vu avec la femme lorsque son rôle
des constructeurs aura été refusée on
pourra le jeter d'ailleurs comme j'ai
dit au début dans la définition le
lotissement n'a rien à faire des
minorités non occidentales ils veulent
des minorités qui peuvent déconstruire
l'occident donc les minorités dans
d'autres pays dans d'autres continents
cd et des dvd des données inintéressante
on pourrait dire que entre le
l'antiracisme des années 80
qui voulait qu'on soit tous les mêmes
aujourd'hui l'antiracisme celui qu'on
traite tout mouvement go comme notamment
nous voient comme tous différents et ça
déjà c'est une grande différence et qui
explique parfois les réactions et
pourquoi on oppose nouveau cusm à une
bannissent mme ou à l'universalisme
républicain à la française dont nous
sommes si fiers
albin wagner
ouais en fait si vous voulez c'est ça le
souci aussi c'est qu'on a un filtre
là-dessus qui est quand même enfin la
manière dont le débat pour moi s'engage
en france qu'il est très franco-français
aussi parce que enfin faut pas qu'il
faut pas oublier encore une fois le
contexte général on est dans un contexte
vous parlez beaucoup disent là le
terrorisme d'islamophobie donc forcément
tord assistons actuellement
effectivement coude à coude entre entre
marine le pen et eric zemmour en fait
encore il ya des hommes des femmes
politiques qui se réclament de l'extrême
droite aujourd'hui quand même aussi qui
le portent tout à fait sereinement dans
les sondages à minimale en fait je pense
qu'eric zemmour en tout cas
lui ne dirais pas oui c'est encore une
fois la question de l'éthique est vous
parler du fait que c'est important que
les gens à fumer une étiquette pour
qu'elle soit valide aujourd'hui personne
ne s'en réclament dans le débat public
donc est ce que est ce qu'on jette il
faut choisir soit en gt2 étiquette fond
n'en est aucune écoute et on peut jeter
dans ce cas là mais bon je te fuis moi
je veux bien si vous voulez le truc
c'est que veut pas dire que les risées
n'ont vu que il ne dit que ce serait moi
tu n'es pas d' extrêmement que les
personnes qui ne se réclament pas du
rookie ce ne sont pas vos qu il faut
seulement voulait elle admire
beaucoup progresser ce soir les
conclusions avec d'autres il s'agit pas
de nécessaire on arrive à des
conclusions ce que je sais ce que je
souhaite moi c'est qu'on ait un échange
aussi qu'ils puissent informer les gens
qui aurait 17 émissions quand vous
parlez en fait de bouddhisme en mêlant
aussi beaucoup de choses à vous parler
de départ et de théories de faire vous
avez évoqué en fait la théorie du genre
vous avez évoqué l' attaque sexualité on
a là aussi quand même il sort d'une
géologie philosophie qui est différente
dans les deux cas thuir la manière dont
guy mollet crenshaw à la base porte
l'intersexualité sauf si j'ai
effectivement ma lui est mal compris
c'est d'abord le fait de montrer qu' il
y à des discriminations qui s'ajoute qui
se multiplient en fait c'est
effectivement des fecteau on n'a pas
tous la même expérience de vie par
rapport à sa par rapport au monde social
bolduc là on est tous je veux dire sur
ce plateau tout à fait ce sera enfin je
veux dire on parle entre gens soient
effectivement universitaires
journalistes intellectuels c'est facile
on a une expérience de la vie qui venait
pas celle effectivement d'une d'une
femme de ménage dans un hôtel ibis qui
évite en fait à la courneuve par exemple
un fou rire par rapport à ça je veux
dire la parole elle est et ça c'est
quelque chose qui est propre sciences
sociales depuis longtemps et ça n'a rien
à voir avec le postmodernisme le fait de
la d'avoir une parole situé puisque vous
avez même des collègues d'ailleurs qui
sont en fait de droite pour pas pour le
dire telle quelle économie lasserre qui
se réclament justement d'une chose d'une
linguistique situé au lieu dit situé
qu'à dire oui en tant que chercheur
abandonné quand on va voi à étudier un
fait social politique historique la
musique ce que vous voulez on situe en
fait une étude par rapport à un cadre en
fait épistémologique par rapport à 4
méthodologique donc en fait à partir du
moment où on va parler du mot qui sema
faut savoir d'où l'on parle et qu'est ce
qu'on désigne
effectivement le mot guise mme c'est une
grosse boîte dans quelle boîte noire
mais on pourrait dire dans lequel on est
un petit peu de tout c'est à dire que
l'on va voir la théorie du genre de la
taxe nationalité la théorie critique de
la race to sah matinée en fait d'abord
de quelque chose qui est aussi enfin ça
se touche en tant qu'homme en tout cas
ce soir avant que j'ai mal compris
quelque chose qui va leur qu'il va dire
mais tout ça de manière intégrale est
une menace pour la concorde en
démocratie mais bon en tout cas pour le
droit la d'histoire nous mêmes ou de
désaccord pardon alba je vous interromps
parce qu' on est obligé de faire une
pause là je me rendrai la parole juste
après et on repartira pas du même
endroit
[Musique]
il ya eu celle et panama peppers les
paradise peppers place aujourd'hui aux
pandora peppers la plupart de ces de ces
opérations sont en fait parfaitement
légale y a rien de nouveau sous le
soleil on révèle effectivement un
système dans lequel il ya probablement
enfin incontestablement de plus en plus
de fuite devant l'impôt de plus en plus
de correction et de plus en plus de
difficulté des gouvernements avoir un
brin de contrôle sur ces masses d'argent
qui circule on pourrait simplement
arrêté au-delà ware ou dans d'autres
états comme ça de permettre ces
fonctionnements et c'est blanchiment est
ce que vous pensez sérieusement que
demain le dakota du sud va arrêter ses
pratiques et qu'on va lui faire arrêter
ces pratiques non pas du tout
[Musique]
c'est vraiment un choix pour les
inspecteurs du guide michelin de mettre
cette année en particulier voilà moscou
en avant et sur ces dernières années nos
inspecteurs ont pu noter une vraie
évolution de la scène culinaire de
moscou et puis de plus en plus de
concept de restaurant et avec des chefs
qui ont une vraie signature dans leur
cuisine c'est en observant ce
développement que vous êtes dit on va
aller voir de plus près ce qui se passe
en russie moscou est un vrai carrefour
un vrai carrefour d'influencés un vrai
carrefour de deux cultures donc il ya un
vrai brassage donc il ya une très très
grande diversité des types de cuisine
moscou en particulier a une saveur
particulière
a ajouté à la scène gastronomique
mondiale
[Musique]
on reprend ce débat sur le moc isme avec
pierre valentin qui est membre du
laboratoire république à 1 2 jean michel
blanquer et avec calvin balbin wagner
qui est docteur en sciences du langage
on est en train de de voir pourquoi est
ce que les antilles walk aqueuse le voc
isme d'être
hostile de s'opposer à l'humanisme à
l'universalisme
et même à l'histoire de france je vous
rends la parole alba wagner
merci mais ce que je voudrais simplement
vous précisez vos pas monopoliser trop
trop trop la parole non plus c'est de
dire que en fait dans tout ça dans ce
creuset qu'on appelle le bloquiste et
que je distingue vraiment du mouvement
ou encore une fois il ya plusieurs
choses par exemple quand des théories du
genre on parle bien de des théories du
genre il y en a plusieurs et plusieurs
courants d'ailleurs il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de courants qui sont carrément
en fait en bisbille les uns avec les
autres il ya effectivement des anciens
parce que ce sont des courants la
philosophie que nos six militants je
voudrais revenir là dessus quand même
parce que on est en train en fait on en
parle sans vous parler et c'est pas un
gros mot ou un militantisme il ya de
l'attentisme de fin de tous les côtés
puisque en fait concrètement on est dans
une démocratie et donc fatalement vous
avez en fait des groupes des
associations des communautés qui vont
vouloir en fait
jouer la partition ou en fait obtenir
aussi gain de cause du promu politique
dans le militantisme puisqu'en fait les
tous les tous les exemples concon cité
qu'on a encore cité mise à part lille et
grenoble qui se trouvent les états unis
dans toute action militante le but c'est
ça soit est largement aussi étudié le
but c'est de pouvoir essayer de trouver
des actions ou porter des paroles qui
vont on va dire
en fait montré aux gens qui se passe
quelque chose qu'il faut en faire
défendre cette cause est d'accord donc
s'attirer l'attention en fait et
évidemment donc dans tout acte militant
quel qu'il soit je lis à quel qu'il soit
quel que soit le bord politique j'ai là
pour le coup j'ai aucun problème avec ça
il ya des risques d'abus aux dérapages
puisque le but c'est de faire parler de
soi quand même et ça c'est quelque chose
qui a aussi été assez largement théorisé
d'une mise en oeuvre par exemple par
greenpeace au siècle dernier ça paraît
qu'en juillet soit on est tous très
travaillé là tout de suite ce coupé est
donc nécessairement c'est d'ailleurs
aussi ensuite une rupture entre
greenpeace puis six chapelles en de
l'autre côté donc puisqu'on voit aussi
je lis c'est quelque chose que j'entends
beaucoup puisque je suis aussi expert en
analyse de dispo pour la fondation
européenne pour le climat de temps en
temps et en fait je vois beaucoup aussi
du côté des associations qui se battent
par rapport aux changements climatiques
les accusations de boki sme en fait de
dire que l'on dise c'est devenu aussi
enfin dans la bouche de ceux qui sont
qui se moque en tout cas de ces
associations là le mot peace now si ces
gens qui vont dire qu'il faut faire
attention au climat donc à bout d'un
moment on mélangeait énormément de
sujets et c'est aussi et là pour le coup
c'est pas c'est pas forcément qui dit
c'est aussi quelque chose qui apporte
crédit de l'agent d'un conservateur de
créer des catégories qui vont ensuite
être vidangé les unes avec les autres et
de créer une grande confusion or il faut
quand même bien comprendre que si on
s'intéresse un tout petit peu
effectivement par exemple aux études
intersectionnelle au pluriel on va voir
que c'est peut-être un peu moins
effrayant que ça en a l'air en fait
quand mon lit tout simplement qui a
effectivement des positions radicales et
position mesurée des positions
démocratique des positions qui le sont
moins mais comme dans tout courant
d'idées en fait évidemment au fur et à
mesure les choses vont se passer on
pourrait aussi parler que tu perds
inclusif par exemple un temps que la
nuit ça m'intéresserait de savoir ce que
vous en pensez
jallet j'allais mettre ça sur le sur la
table parce que parmi les injustices des
discriminations qui sont auquel les
banques sont censées rester vigilants et
d'ailleurs le sont parce qu'on voit bien
que chez les 18-35 ans l'avait cité
d'ailleurs sur la fracture qui j'ai
l'intuition par l'ifop frédéric dabi en
a fait tout un livre appartient une
grande étude d'opinion chez les 18-35
ans rend compte qu'ils sont beaucoup
plus rock que leurs aînés parce que les
sols parce qu'ils sont sensibles à un
certain nombre de la justice de
discrimination alors on pourrait dire
par exemple tous ceux qui avaient aucun
racisme systémique pour vous son book ce
sel qu'un qui a qui vont dire qu'il ya
ainsi ce sexisme systémique à patriarcat
c'est du rock bien sûr aussi ceux qui
invoquent le privilège blanc qui dénonce
le privilège blanc ce que vous appeliez
l'a blanchi tu es tout à l'heure comme
nous on parle de la négritude mais la
négritude c'était c'est un mouvement
créé par aimé césaire
mais dans la blanche it et évidemment
c'est très différent il y aurait un
groupe qui seraient les blancs et les
blancs ne se considère pas comme un
groupe gdg vous répondra donc mais juste
le désir il ya aussi le plafond de verre
dont parlent les femmes mais aussi ceux
qui s'estiment racisées il parle d'un
plafond de verre c'est du hockey tous
ceux qui s'estiment racisées pour des
questions de religion d'ethnie
d'orientation sexuelle de genre là on
peut mettre les trans aussi là aussi ce
serait duo qui aurait tout ça dans le
wok is bien sûr et c'est un truc un
écueil que je vais éviter parfois
lorsque j'en parle on dit oui mais vous
venez parler par exemple d'un éloge de
la fluidité et là vous parlez d'un
essentialisme rigide donc vous vous
contredisez en fait c'est pas moi qui me
contredis c'est l'idéologie qui se
contredit dire que dote d'un côté ils
vont vous dire ils vont existential is
et fluidifier en disant non mais ça
c'est par exemple ça c'est quelque chose
que le l'homme et la femme pourrait
faire également l inverse non non ça
c'est un poste qui doit être pris par
une femme donc à la catégorie femmes
existent dans le second cas de figure
elle n'existe pas dans le premier donc
c'est pile je gagne face tu perds et
l'intersexualité je vais d'accord avec
vous sur ce que vous avez dit je je
pense pas que kimberley crenshaw
s'attendait à ce que ses théories soit
utilisée comme ça elle écrit un premier
papier académique en 89 un second 91 le
problème c'est que si vraiment on veut
dire est ce que c'est de sa faute ou pas
elle a une plateforme médiatique encore
énorme aujourd'hui elle ne s'est jamais
bougé pour dire non on a fait de ma
théorie ce qu'on n'aurait pas dû en
faire elle n'a jamais cherché à arrêter
les plus radicaux d'entre eux alors
l'autre chose que j'aimerais dire c'est
que le ska de point central entre ces
différentes choses que vous avez en
effet listé des choses très différentes
j'ai compris l'écriture a pu vivre bien
ce qui est censé se défendre quand tu
d'écriture patriarcale et douillet on
comprend qu'elle question inclusive
qu'en creux la langue serait fasciste
comme on disait déjà ces requêtes
toujours cette idée que je prends
l'illustration de la théorie critique de
la race qui la plus claire là dessus la
théorie critique de dollars à s'est
fondé sur deux prémisses la première le
racisme et le pire péché qui existe et
la seconde il est intégralement dans
notre système dans nos structures dans
nos normes dans nos dans nos structures
de pouvoir dans la hiérarchie de
domination dans notre langage dans notre
manière de serrer la main pour ceux qui
vont plus loin les micros agression
raciste si vous voulez peuvent être
potentiellement partout parce qu'il
suffit qu'une minorité perçoivent
quelque chose que mettons du racisme
pour que des facto ça en devienne donc
on a un biais de confirmation qui est
déjà stratosphérique et face à ça ça se
décline de manière différente la langue
le mal est partout on va faire une autre
langue
le racisme il est partout donc c'était
assez pratique voie qu'ont assisté mise
et on n'a plus besoin de donner des
preuves de six mois je vous dis telle
personne at-elle jours a commis un acte
raciste on va être obligés de vérifier
ces falsifiable lorsque vous dis que le
système est raciste jemappes ou de la
charge de la preuve n'est plus à
vérifier et donc il ya toujours cette
idée que les dominants et créé le
système est un côté très incertain
complotisme par moments le système a été
créé par des dominants pour leurs
privilèges et ils vont chercher à
opprimer les marginaliser c'est à dire
que ça c'est le point commun de toutes
ces théories différentes vous ne
trouverez pas une théorie qui rentrent
pas dans ce cadre là donc de ce point de
vue là ce terme pas un pli go qui
regroupe en effet théorie critique de la
race indigène isme et ses écritures
inclusive toutes ces choses là ont un
même parapluie qu'est de dire notre
système est abominable nous ne pouvons
pas comme on l'a dit à leur faire des
petits un amendement avec ce système
c'est le mal incarné il faut le détruire
il ya une fameuse phrase qui revient
souvent en anglais we want
en gros on va pas de défaire la maison
du maître avec les outils du mat rire
qu'il faut repenser tous les outils
linguistiques les autistes sociologique
afin de sortir de notre paradigme de la
blanche cité notre paradigme occidental
pour reconstruire une fois qu'on aura
tout détruit à partir des cendres
quelque chose de radicalement nouveau ça
demande pas ça cherche à décoloniser si
vous voulez albin wagner je me demande
de quel côté du complotisme là quand
même quand je vous écoute parce que fout
complètement fin je vois enfin sauf si
je suis totalement aveugle et sourd j'ai
pas tranquille qui a conclu rock dont le
but serait à une fille est de renverser
la société totalement fin en france en
tout cas est ce que les étés dans
l'ondam à croiser écrit pour le couper
décaler ce qu'elle écrit et dans quel
type d'enquêté d'épistémologie parce
qu'en fait si vous voulez encore une
fois la visite des deux luys contredit
mais c'est pas l'idéologie qui sont
redit on vient de dire effectivement
qu'on a des courants très très diverses
et courants se contredisent nez si vous
en faites une idéologie forcément vous
allez voir des choses sont tellement en
contradiction les unes avec les autres
comme si moi je décide faire en fait
d'un bloc idéologique de droite alors ce
qu'il ya des droits attendait des
gauchos via découvrant écolo
environnementaux par exemple et gauche
domine qui n'est pas brook
louis qui ne refais qu'il veut pas
remettre en tout cas c'est clair n
attendait bien d'accord en fait je pense
que du coup là dessus on a encore enfin
je pense qu'il faut vraiment comment
dire je pense qu'ils vont faire
attention de quoi on parle et pas tout
mélanger parce que quand je parle de ce
turn 2 d'écologie c'est pas pour
ressortir de le débarrasser au programme
mais je veux dire
quand on va effectivement quand vous
avez des militants écolos qui vont sur
un traité de mort parce qu'en fait il
sombre pour changer les choses par
rapport aux changements climatiques
typiquement la manière dont les choses
sont en train de s'accélérer on ad on a
des informations tous les jours depuis
la iii c'est une que les autres avec des
vrais chiffres des vraies statistiques
des choses totalement concrètes en fait
qu'ils sont liés aux sciences dures donc
on ne m'aime pas les taxes et
d'idéologie encore que évidemment il ya
aussi des de lui dans les sciences dures
mais qui nous montrent qu'en fait
finalement
on va devoir changer radicalement de
système pour pouvoir en fait survivre
concrètement c'est un petit plus alors
là évidemment il s'agit pas dire que
dans la langue française en fête il faut
changer radicalement de langue pour
pouvoir survivre mais si je prends par
exemple le cas d'écriture accusent ils
là en tant que linguiste moi le rôle du
chercheur c'est d'observer ce qui se
passe d'accord c'est comme ça que
j'envisage mais c'est à dire je prends
pas position enfin la proposition
évidemment ton citoyens mais ça c'est
mon problème mais en tant que chercheur
je dois observer des faits
l'écriture inclusive en ce moment c'est
effectivement une écriture qui est
militante qui propose en fait un
changement en fait dans la graphie enfin
dans la file pour le point médian parce
que souvent on réduit d'écriture
inclusive au pr média ce sont deux
choses différentes quand le général de
gaulle dit françaises français il fait
tellement rire cuisines en fête
concrètement donc ce son ballon mais
c'est une réalité
c'est ce que je viens de vous dire bien
sûr des grands accords très bien je vais
vous dire c'est que la langue
instructive la langue inclusive c'est
quelque chose qui date de très longtemps
et en fait si vous lisez quelque chose
quelques éléments linguistiques si vous
lisez par exemple des études très
décente de basket j sur l'écriture
inclusive en fait tout ce qu'on imagine
comme comme on va dire comme effet
totalement négatif par exemple sur les
gens c'est pas forcément vrai d'une part
et d'autre ce sont des expérimentations
moi je regarde c'est à dire que la
langue elle évolue les sociétés évoluent
quand le veuille ou non sinon c'est à
dire qu'on écrit là encore l'ancien
françois d'il ya cinq cents ans par
exemple or ce n'est pas le cas on ne
parle pas non plus donc vous avez
forcément des choses qui évolue la
société elle bouge elle propose des
solutions et des choses qui sont gardés
d'accord a qui vont en fait sans
intégrer petit à petit donc qui sont de
toute façon en fait rejeter peut-être
que l'écriture est plus vive entre le
point médian ça se trouve on ne parlera
plus dans 50 ans sera pas pris et pointe
à la ligne si vous voulez mais moi je
fais aussi confiance finalement en
remédiant à l'aller oui on si vous
voulez mais si eux aussi aux citoyennes
et aux citoyens pour pouvoir se
positionner là dessus je pense que
d'abord quand vous parlez en fait je le
fais j'ai pas d'hélicoptère chercheurs a
comme tout le monde j'ai fait des choses
qui ont fait un blessé très très
différents mais quand je leur parle de
vos qu'ils savent même pas ce que ça
veut dire c'est quoi encore cette
connerie a fait ça que j'entends de
cette fois personnellement donc en fait
là le débat qu'on a il concerne aussi
des leaders d'opinion il concerne des
hommes et des femmes politiques qui en
font un beurre aussi parce que bon il ya
aussi cette idée là quand vous avez à
longueur de temps que papa de la défense
pour le coup mais d'autres d'autres
chaînes concurrentes qui passent leur
temps à ne parler que de ça que de ça
que de ça parce qu'en fait ça leur fait
de l'audience sur pied un fonds de
commerce de parler de l'occident ça peut
en être un j'aimerais
dire je salue la teneur du débat je suis
pas habitué à voir des débats aussi
calme et constructif sur ces sujets donc
je veux j'en suis ravi
on cite souvent ça m'arrive tout le
temps le donc le fameux sondage ifop
réalisé en février dernier publié en
mars pour l'express on va vous dire 14%
des français ont entendu parler du
mutisme et seuls 6% ça ce que ça veut
dire arrêtons d'en faire tout un plat
c'est là l'argument que j'entends il ya
plusieurs problèmes c'est que
premièrement c'est un sondage réalisé en
février comme vous l'avez fait remarquer
on en a beaucoup parlé récemment je
pense que si on refait ce sondage
aujourd'hui on aurait des chiffres
sensiblement différent et deuxièmement
lorsqu'on regarde les concepts phares
montcuq racisme systémique écriture
inclusive et c'est accepter ça la
majeure partie des français ont déjà
entendu parler donc dire les français
vous en faites à quoi on fait référence
avec des termes différents moi ce stade
j'ai pas trouvé de meilleurs termes que
brooke ensuite pour revenir sur
l'écriture inclusive il ya une
distinction entre une écriture
militantes comme vous dites comme vous
dites qui par duo qui par exemple au
sein d'administrations de la sorbonne
entre autres est banalisée et même
parfois il ya des étudiants qui doivent
renvoyer leur copie parce qu'elle n'a
pas été rédigé en inclusive ça c'est une
manière si vous voulez agressive qui par
duo de mettre les choses en place et
comme vous le dites l'évolution du vieux
françois qui sur des siècles en partant
du bas connaît des fluctuations c'est
compliqué il faut être constructive
eastbourne il a la distinction entre une
évolution organique et une évolution
artificiel ensuite encore sur l'écriture
inclusive vous avez sans doute en tête
l'écriture inclusive qui est voué à
devenir réactionnaire d'ici un an ou
deux et à l'écriture inclusive où ces
étudiantes point e point s en belgique y
avait des jeunes gens qui s'étaient
écologistes il faudrait vérifier si
rajouter point e point s point x à la
fin parce que ça inclut également les
noms binaire et donc on aura donc des
féministes qui dans deux ans seront
traitées de réactionnaire on voit que
par exemple jermaine greer donc celle
qui a écrit la femme unique qui était
tête de proue du féminisme radical la
plus progressiste qu'on puisse imaginer
au broc avant l'heure si on veut même si
elles vont évidemment c'est différent à
l'époque elle se fait annuler elle n'a
plus droit de cité sur les campus du
royaume uni et jerry rawlings pareil qui
était le jeu harry potter c'est le seul
livre que ces personnes avaient lu et
même elle qui était sacré lisez s'est
fait descendre en flammes pour avoir dit
une banalité les fonds ce que vous
reprochez vous personnellement au voc
isme c'est quand il veut quand il
devient un mouvement
terrorisant les quant au fond il veut
interdire de parler certaines personnes
ou les interdire même de travailler dans
certains cas mais est-ce que ça arrive
aussi souvent que cela en tout cas en
france ça n'est pas arrivé à parler
d'eux les deux professeurs de lierop est
coriace
qui est le fait qu est ce qui est
intéressant c'est que déjà il faut
comprendre une première chose c'est que
un professeur viré ou alors encore
encore mieux entre guillemets menacé d'
islamophobie quelques mois après la
décapitation de semaine elle pâtit c'est
sans professeurs qui se taisent les
autres comprennent le message dont il
suffit si vous voulez que le bout de
l'iceberg soient bien visibles pour que
tout en bas ça ce gel et ça ne disent
plus rien ensuite j'ai trouvé ça assez
dommage tout à l'heure quand vous vous
avez dit faites il ya des chercheurs des
gens sérieux qui n'ont pas de prisme et
ensuite il ya des gens soient motivées
politiquement c'est à dire pas neutres
des charlatans si on comprend en creux
et d'autres universitaires idéologisé il
y aurait des gens non idéologisé et des
gens idéologisé et l'observateur du des
colonialistes pour le coup à faire un
rapport très complet sur la question il
ya dix-sept pages d'exemples de quand
cette culture au sein du monde
universitaire avec des profs qui perdent
des contrats des conférences qui sont
annulés les gens qui perdent des emplois
est pareil une personne virer ce soit
sans personne qui se taisent et donc je
suis si vraiment il fallait donner un
mérite à la philosophie postmoderne qui
en a qui est donc le précurseur du
gauchisme à certains égards m6 que vous
qui se meurent a trahi par d'autres on
refera pas seul ce débat ce soir c'est
que chacun a une perspective en fait il
n'y a pas des gens neutres et des gens
qui n'ont pas de perspective il n'y a
pas des gens qui ont un prisme et des
gens qui n'ont pas de lunettes
idéologique tout le monde a une
perspective et je trouve ça dommage que
tout à l'heure vous a laissé dire
maintenant il ya des chercheurs et
ensuite et des idéologues dans le monde
universitaire il ya des gens qui se sont
plaints de ça et ce qui m'a frappé avec
cet article de france info donc auquel
vous avez participé c'est toute la
question du duo keith mme c si si ça
existe c'est dans le monde universitaire
c'est mon anniversaire culture le
premier de ces choses là donc qu'est-ce
qu'on va faire on va tendre au micro à
quelqu'un qui représente le monde
universitaire c'est à dire vous ce soir
et le dire est ce que c'est vrai que le
monde universitaire et est infestée par
ça et bizarrement le monde universitaire
qui juge et partie répond ah non non le
rookie ce n'est pas un problème chez
nous donc il si vous laissez un à une
argumentation c'est un argumentaire qui
ne se tient pas on peut pas être à la
fois juge et partie de cette question
mais c'est la même chose enfin on a mis
la chose pour l'islamo gauchisme c'était
ridicule en fait parce que si vous
voulez on peut aussi avoir des anecdotes
sur le fait que des gens qui enfin
actuellement on a des universités
passants qui vont interdire des études
entière justement d'éviter conservatrice
aussi donc ça existe aussi aux états
unis ça par exemple moi personnellement
j'ai eu aussi dans le moment passé en
fait maille à partir dans une autre
université
ou en fait on interdisait aussi des
conférences par screen aller dans la
nuit en fait de deux sous la direction
souhaitait et que c'était plutôt dans
les mines conservatrices donc c'est dans
les deux cas sauf que dans un cas on en
parle beaucoup on en fait tout un plat
dans notre coeur non pas un petit peu
moins non mais c'est aussi une réalité
quand même si les styles les statuts qui
t'ont je vais dans un sens et pas dans
l'autre si nécessaire les salles us
intéressant je vais y revenir le statut
tire très bien merci pour le voir le
truc c'est que par exemple pour
l'évolution de la langue organique
l'artificiel s'intéresse à ce que vous
dites on est bien d'accord que le point
médian est une proposition qui est
effectivement artificielle et c'est une
évolution organique de la langue ou
artificiels le français a été quand même
une langue qui était partiellement créé
par des gens qui n'ont réécrite pour
être sûr plus esthétique là dans ce
genre évolution artificielle ne fait pas
mieux quand même et là pour le coup
enfin je m'excuse je n'ai donc dans la
trilogie de sam dans l'histoire de frais
langue française enfin il ya surtout
beaucoup d'évolutions artificiel donc ce
sont des choses qui existent aussi à
partir devant vous avez en fait des
rapports de pouvoir des gens qui ont les
moyens de peser dans la graphie dans la
déclinaison par rapport à la langue
forcément ils vont avoir le pouvoir de
le faire et donc ça va se reposer comme
une norme à toutes et à tous et ça c'est
un autre problème serait l'enfance ase
et malheureusement les mains tachées de
sang par rapport à ça mais c'est un
autre débat je viens simplement
effectivement ça parce qu'il ignorait ce
qui est venue alors sketches extraits il
faut il faut en parler rapidement les
statuts c'est un truc intéressant il ya
eu des abus il ya eu aussi le fait de
pouvoir utiliser les statuts en
recontextualise ans parce que quand on
en fait on entend beaucoup de cas quand
on enlève ses statuts la roue cantons
rpt pâtissent des noms de rue d'ailleurs
tous les pays passeur leur histoire leur
siècle alors baptisés de noms de rues
ils avaient des statuaires en enlever
quand ont déboulonné une statue de
lénine ça va crier personne évidemment
donc
depuis la rome antique j'ai fait un
petit guide de recherche là dessus dans
sa tombe bien depuis la rome antique qui
a des cas et des cas et des canaux
statue déboulonnée dû redonner de
monuments enlevé déconstruite c'est pour
des raisons en fait effectivement soit
politique de domination c'est vous avez
quelqu'un qui prend possession d'une
ville ou d'un pays et bim là on a
évidemment on passe d'un régime est un
autre oui on enlève tout élève à la
loire est éloquent symbole
soit effectivement vous avez là et je
voudrais revenir là dessus quand même
parce que ya pas une épidémie de
déboulonnage de statut bien quand même
avant je veux dire c'est pas la fin de
ma note notamment au royaume-uni une
dans l'instant la conclusion du second
volume de la note vous pouvez aller voir
une note de bas de page qui renvoie vers
un site qui liste tous les déboulonnage
de statut au royaume uni et si on peut
pas parler d'épidémie dans ce cas là je
ne peux pas parler d'épidémie de covin
si vous voulez dire que l'on va
mais dont on parle bien de la france la
haine pour l'instant moi j'ai pas vu
trop trop statut qui sont tombés en
france on a on a déplacé en tout cas
celle de napoléon au notamment à arreau
et en fait si vous voulez voilà donc une
donc une bonne épidémie mais ceci étant
dit ce que je veux dire aussi par là
c'est que derrière ça montre une autre
chose c'est que et là je reviens sur des
publics à nice mme qui impose des
symboles sans forcément décontextualisés
et sont plus d'expliquer quand vous avez
ça c'est le cas de l'histoire en général
vous raconter d'histoires faut inventer
l'histoire évidemment c'est un peu une
tarte à la crème veux le dire mais de
celles et ceux qui grosso modo mentir il
reconnu l'histoire voilà l'histoire de
france elle est racontée par ceux qui
ont eu en fait le pouvoir à qui ont
exercé et qui vont en fait donné leur
version d'histoire et c'est tout à fait
normal la science de l'histoire les
collections historiens enfin je vais pas
semblé dire des bêtises malheureusement
je ne suis pas historien mais de ce que
j'en comprends quand même pour en
courant lire c'est que vous avez sur un
fait historique vous avez vraiment
parfois des points de vue très très très
divers parfois même totalement opposées
pour l'expliquer moi je trouve ça plutôt
intéressant au-delà du symbole de la
stature je vous a plutôt intéressant
aussi qu'on se dise mais quelle histoire
en train de raconter et il ya des gens
effectivement qu'ils ont sur territoire
qui en fait vivent l'histoire qu'on
raconte de manière en fait quand un
discriminant très clairement que cette
discrimination aussi d'accord il s'agit
pas de dire je devais pas dix ans il
s'agit pas de dire et puis en fait le
mot qui sera en fait dit il ya des
discriminations par tour l'art en fête
y'en a pas évidemment qu'il y en a il
faut des raisons de ces discriminations
là et il faut aussi résoudre cette
problématique cette thématique très très
forte qui et comment est-ce qu'on se
réapproprie l'histoire et est ce que
l'histoire peut être enseigné avec des
points de vue multiples et je pense que
ce serait bien le problème c'est que là
aussi on a en france une vision
extrêmement verticale de la manière dont
on exerce en fait le pouvoir politique
et quand vous regardez notre démocratie
en europe par exemple on ne se tourner
que vers nos voisins
vous avez une autre manière de concevoir
par exemple les programmes ne serait-ce
que ça d'éducation
d'obtenir mon visage et
l'enseignement de l'histoire aussi donc
on est en train en fait de aussi de ne
pas vouloir autre chose mise à part
effectivement les abus militants d'un
côté je jeu ça clairement en attendant
vous la voir autre chose qui est il ya
d'être une autre manière d'incarner la
république où les principes fondateurs
de la république et il ya des gens qui
ne s'y connaissent absolument plus et ça
c'est très très grave et moi ça veut
vraiment dire à ces gens là mais vous
dites et vous faites n'importe quoi
c'est pas grave on va passer à autre
chose on va imposer notre point de vue
comme l'a fait jean michel blanquer
demande aux enseignants de en fait quand
même d'avoir un cadre très très fort ce
rapport à la république extrêmement
choquant de la part d'amis ça c'est mon
problème donc en fait je pense que là il
ya aussi quelque chose de fondamental à
travailler pour justement remettre l âge
fait référence à un ouvrage que j'ai pu
pour encadrer avec des collègues et avec
qui je suis pas toujours d'accord
d'ailleurs dans sa tombe très bien avec
jérôme travaille avec nicolas sur la
valeur du désaccord et où en fait le
problème dans cette démocratie dans la
manière dont cette démocratie fonctionne
c'est que le désaccord n'est plus
possible là il est ce soir je m'en
réjouis on n'est pas d'accord on peut se
dire très clairement c'est très bien
sens en ce sens affublés de noms
d'oiseaux mais effectivement retrouvé ce
terrain là et pouvoir en fait
approfondir chaque sujet sans se mettre
de hyères en exposant tous les points de
vue qui existent toutes les études qui
existent et les travailler vraiment à
fond je vous ai j'aimerais vraiment
rebondir là dessus je suis d'accord
qu'on a eu un long débat très calme et
très intéressant était vraiment bon
moment à passer et
justement ces débats là ne seront plus
possibles dire que pour avoir fait les
débats avec des vraies personnes brooks
est impossible de débattre on est
forcément dans les noms d'oiseaux comme
vous dites et d'autres idéologies
forcément d'autres militants ont parfois
des dérives sauf que là le problème
c'est que ado mines m normalement être
institutionnalisé à dire que en tant que
vous monsieur vous qui êtes de bonne foi
et qui est honnête intellectuellement en
tant que mâle blanc j'ai pas votre âge
peut peut-être hétérosexuels normalement
dans un monde normal on s'en fiche mais
ça serait autant s'ils voulaient de
pierres dans votre jardin ils iront
fouiller sur vous dire on retient mais
c'est pas celui qui est deux dans la
musique et a donné du lustre au
troisième reich par exemple et ils
trouveront des chaussures vous
anachronisme inculture on s'en fiche le
rapport à la pureté fait que tout le
monde y passera à lorsqu'on voit que
même caitlin jenner inquiété dans une
transgenre qui était très médiatisée en
amérique qui était du coup vu comme la
pointe du mouvement au qui avait fait
des unes de médias dans tous les sens
elle peut être annulée si je puis dire
où en tout cas violemment critiqué sur
les réseaux avec une virulence
extraordinaire parce que l a dit ben en
fait moi dans mon état américain je ne
pense pas que les garçons et par les
filles et les garçons qui se réclament
du sexe féminin peuvent jouer des jeux
de sport ensemble parce que va y avoir
des accidents il suffit qu'elle ait dit
ça pour ce faire annuler donc je pense
aussi par exemple à
pascal blanchard qui n' a une relation
avec les indigéniste où ils caressent le
tigre de temps en temps il va dans leur
sens tant il se prend un coup de griffe
lorsque rien bouteldja le disqualifier
en tant qu'intellectuel blanc et
pourtant ils continuent à virevolter un
coup oui un coup non et ces gens là
pensent pouvoir en fait acheter la paix
sociale avec ce mouvement ce mouvement
la voix chez les dominants des personnes
à faire disparaître c'est le vrai sens
de leur utilisation du terme de
diversité diversité dans leur bouche
c'est également le cas chez rhodia
bouteldja qui se gargarisent de noix
risée de berbérie zay de créolisé de
islamiser la france parce que la grande
chose s'avère moins dominants donc les
dominants faut bien comprendre leurs
jours sont comptés il n'y a pas de
concession avec eux toute concession que
vous vous leur faites c'est pour eux un
signe de fragilité fragilité blanche qui
en appellera d'autres c'est le signe du
début de leur victoire et avec ses si
vous voulez ces néo robespierre il faut
bien comprendre quelque chose lorsque
vous vous allez un peu dans leur sens
lorsque vous nuancée alors que non mais
c'est plus compliqué que ça ils ont été
mal compris il existerait oxymore s'il
en est un autisme modéré et bien vous
êtes en train finalement de négocier le
luxe d'être guillotiné en dernier c'est
tout je préciserai puisque ce sera le
dernier mot que la fois au reboot est
déjà que l'étonnant de ceux qui luttent
contre la transphobie sont venus aussi
dans cette émission elle s'appelle
interdit d'interdire dont godard se fait
absolument tout le monde on a débattu
bien sûr tant de la même façon avec
autant le calme et d'ouverture d'esprit
sur tous les sujets le des colonialismes
la transphobie et c'est la question
trans qu'on l'a fait ce soir et je vous
en remercie sur le walk isme merci tous
les deux d'avoir participé à ce débat
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]
maman